[Music]
hey everyone we're getting to that time
of year again here at GameSpot where we
go back over the entire year for Game of
the Year deliberations and we look back
at Microsoft Sony Nintendo PC and BR
this is our Microsoft panel looking back
in Microsoft's Year in Review I'm Mike
my Hardy here with Peter Brown Justin
hey whoa howdy howdy we're gonna talk
about Microsoft Xbox Windows 10 all
those kind of things say I want to start
off earlier in the year and throughout
the year they've been updating in
general I think it was October we
finally got to a point where a lot of us
were saying how the UI and everything
for the Xbox one is actually good Pete
did you notice this throughout the year
like between the creator's update in
March that's when I just mentioning the
fall update do you think it finally
settled on something that's pretty
usable in general for their interface I
still have like nitpicks with it when I
use it today but it is a vastly improved
version of the UI that they introduced a
couple years ago and have it yeah like
even before this year they were
incrementally updating it they're in a
far better place now I don't know that
that necessarily gonna make me more
sweeping changes but I'm happier to see
a xbox where it is I do want to get to
some of the games and whatnot the
cancellations delays and what exclusives
they did have but first Justin did you
have any experience this year with like
backwards compatibility only that is the
big success story for Microsoft in this
year is that is that they've been
introducing it and this was the I think
when we were at e3 like them saying that
not only do you not need to go to a
different service if you have Xbox 360
games and now if you have Xbox one games
that those will just work on your system
and like as a as a longtime gamer is
someone who has a lot of these games in
this library like that that is kind of
exciting and especially that draws the
line against them and PlayStation where
Playstations still doesn't allow you to
play a lot of ps3 games even if you have
the digital versions of them if you want
to play these games that you have in
your library you have to go to
PlayStation now you have to go to a
different service and you have to pay
for it and that to me is the biggest
differentiator and kind of the biggest
positive for Microsoft that it feels
like they're feeding into those old fans
the people who have supported them for a
long time and saying if you want to play
these classic games and you have them in
your digital library if you have a
physical version you can
playin that's my favorite thing about
Microsoft and a lot of them look better
too there's a lot of them are getting
enhanced even for Xbox one acts even
like original Xbox games that's
something that's been going pretty well
since the Xbox one is released right
they've been pretty like up-to-date on
updating those games for free I think I
forget what the like the more like
shadow of war I remember when it came
out with like it's looking pretty good
up front
the Xbox one X speaking you were talking
about e3 they now Phil Spencer took the
stage to talk about how Xbox original
games we're coming to Xbox one backwards
compatibility but the X it went from
project Scorpio to the name that we now
know it and love it as huh but you guys
both have one I believe or Pete you've
got one on day one what's been your
experience with John no I haven't from
the office but I have been using it but
I haven't purchased one yet cuz $500
still seems like a tough pill to swallow
what's been your experience with the
ones that we have been able to get our
hands on it is a beautiful piece of
hardware and I'm someone who like kind
of gravitates toward certain types of
industrial design and this sort of fits
what I look for perfectly now obviously
the aesthetics of a console or like the
least important thing but when you
compare it to the original Xbox one it's
it's again a vast improvement right and
it's it's a system that feels smelt and
modern in that way and then of course
it's super powerful as well and that
seems to be pretty that is maybe more
interested in keeping up with the
Microsoft ecosystem outside of work on
my own personal time like I'm actually
more interested in that now because I
can see a clear difference between the
Scorpio and PlayStation in terms of
power the games are still a bit of a
rocky subject yeah that's the thing that
they haven't really made clear is that
it is clearly a more powerful machine
that it will like it is more capable
than any other console but what it does
on an individual game basis can still be
really unclear even if you own those
games like I don't think they've done a
good job of selling that outside of
they'll look better to some degree but
even even that is it is it upscaling is
it full 4k is it HDR like all of those
kinds of terms I think both get
confusing from a consumer standpoint and
it's also just hard to know like what is
it that's individually better about
these games if I play them on Xbox one X
and it's impossible to talk about at
like Microsoft in general this year
without talking about the kind of
concerning lack of game
right in January right away scalebound
got cancelled from platinum and that was
one of the ones I showed off last year
at e3 and that was kind of ones I don't
know they're gonna send some secession
the Xbox right yeah and now like
crackdown got pushed out of this year as
well we saw that at e3 and the showing
wasn't too impressive and then I think
it was right after e3 in July or
something they said we're actually gonna
push this out of the year
see if thieves we don't know when it's
gonna release yes still just 2018 P is
this lack of game still just an ongoing
concern for Microsoft do they need to
right the ship because we don't even
know when halo 6 is gonna come out if
it's gonna come out we don't know when
Gears of War 5 is gonna be a thing see
the bigger issue to me is that the only
exclusives we can count on looking
forward to it we've seen no clinical
count our sequels to series that we've
seen for years
seriously I'm personally very tired of
I've never been a huge fan of halo halo
3 love that game but I've kind of felt
fallen off after that so I don't
actually necessarily worry about when
halo is coming there's plenty of years
of war games that I haven't played yet
I'm not worried about one the new ones
coming but I'm worried about are the
surprising exclusives like sea of
thieves is one of those it's also been a
game that has not really showcased why I
should be really excited for I mean
system seller is always a weird phrase
but I don't see that yet
I never thought scalebound was going to
be a huge mainstream success but that
was a game that I was like okay this is
exclusive to Xbox I really want to play
it badly to the point that I will invest
in a console and then from there invest
you know and other games as well but
yeah I don't see a reason at least in
terms of my taste right now to look
forward to exclusives that are expected
or exclusives that have already been
announced the ones I'm most excited for
our sequels as well like that
whirring the blind forest sequel
whispering willows I believe is called
or see it's a good point
yeah and then state of decay too but
again those are still on the riser who
knows when they're actually going to and
they're probably gonna come to PC as
well yeah exactly
speaking of PC what about the
cross-platform play between Windows 10
and Xbox is that been a big selling
point for you at all Justin that it's
something that again like that like
backwards compatibility that I think is
a really important part of Xbox but at
the same time it also dilutes it a
little bit that you know who you don't
need I don't necessarily need to upgrade
to an Xbox one X and I haven't
personally purchased one because I can
also get all these experiences on my
I don't have a 4k TV and so for me like
having that access on PC is great like I
love that I'm able to to tie into my
xbox one friends list and and to be able
to get that experience on PC but at the
same time it doesn't make me feel like
it's as necessary to have that console
experience it's great it's smart it's
the thing that differentiates them again
from Playstation but I don't know that
it's the best strategy for something
consoles overall P I'm gonna talk to you
about like what your holistic view of
Xboxes this year Microsoft in general
we've got backwards compatibility they
brought our original Xbox games to the
Xbox one they brought up the Xbox one ax
finally and again we just talked about
kind of concerning lack of exclusives
which seems to be the story of Microsoft
over the past few years but overall
looking back to 2017 how do you think
Microsoft did I think that this was a
great year of growth for them they've
set up an incredible foundation for the
years to come and I just I just really
hope that you know because I want
everyone to succeed and I haven't really
seen success yet for the Xbox one I
would love to see Microsoft do something
with that power and all that goodwill
they burned because I think they're in a
position to do some great stuff doesn't
what's your take
yeah the Xbox it has a firm foundation
and its really what they're gonna do in
2018 like they can they can still pull
out a Nintendo level of surprise and
that's the thing like the Nintendo has
gone from incredible weakness to
incredible strength this year because
they just kind of surprise you they have
a lot of stuff in the back pocket they
have stuff we know that's coming up and
then they have stuff that just releases
on that day and that's the kind of
learning that Microsoft needs to take is
that 2018 I don't really know what's
coming up from Microsoft outside of a
handful of games if they can just
release something if it's like March we
announced and then release something in
like April or May like having that kind
of quick turnaround like that I think is
what would really change the dynamic for
especially between PlayStation of
Microsoft releasing those big games
without us even knowing that they're on
our
yeah and here's hoping we do have a nice
2018 plan from Microsoft in general 2017
for Microsoft that was our panel looking
back on it for the year we were also
talking about Sony Nintendo VR and PC
for games bus game of the year you're in
a review videos here all week so stay
tuned and we'll see you then